the advisors a very bright backlight
Easter counting colors would you contact
Scott Air Force Base to suit that has
inclined them very pleased
whether it's a planet
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 15 of
the 13 o'clock podcast and you knew it
had to happen one of these days we are
eventually getting around to doing a UFO
show got to do UFOs well yeah God do you
have foes and I think this is the best
case to start with yeah I think it's the
most believable UFO case which you know
I like UFO cases but there's a lot of
problems with UFOs
maybe on with UFO cases that there are
too many of them and they can't all be
true so you know I'd say most of its
hoax or misidentification but this one
actually has a lot of witnesses a lot of
credible witnesses that are unrelated
and documentation so we know that this
is something that actually happened yeah
the thing is we just can't identify what
it was right we're just not really sure
entirely what all these people saw yeah
what this case you know is kind of up
there in the fields of UF ology I guess
because one that had a lot of witnesses
that were separated in distance four of
the witnesses were cops from from
different different departments like
from different cities different
jurisdictions all on this all on the
night shift
yeah so the chances of collusion of
pretty low right and they were calling
this in and they actually wrote reports
about it and then there were some just
regular civilian witnesses to it and the
guy who actually reported it was a
civilian so you know it wasn't kicked
off by the cops yeah and then later on
ten years after this case all these guys
passed lie-detector chests yeah and what
was funny about the the lie-detector
test is they asked those cops whether or
not they believed it was you know if
they had believed it was an
extraterrestrial spacecraft and they did
and they they paid on the lie detector
test that says that they actually did
believe that yeah although they never
said that in public that they just they
didn't identify it they just said they
saw something no that thought that was
kind of cool yeah which I mean is fair
enough because I mean the way they
described it it could have been
something else maybe a secret crash
it could have been a secret craft sure I
mean clearly they all saw something
unusual yeah you know I'm not saying it
was aliens polygraph said that they saw
it that they described it accurately and
that they didn't blow it into something
that it wasn't
yeah and the polygraph results said that
they believed that it was an
extraterrestrial spacecraft that's okay
that's kind of cool I think that's
really cool yeah all right so basically
what the timeline was this happened in
southern Illinois in the year 2000 and
what's the matter
oh he's he's playing where my thing is
okay so it happened in the year 2000 um
it's generally known by the name the st.
Claire triangle or UFOs over Illinois
yeah that was the name of the discovery
and yeah there's been some documentary
there it's not a documentaries on it
which we can we can plug those later
yeah
but basically okay so it's January 2000
yeah now the documentary they made about
this they said the first the first
sighting was at for something a.m. but
it was actually the evening before it
was 10:30 p.m.
when was apparently the first sighting
of it and I don't think they added that
information until later on okay so when
a new my name is came through what new
witnesses came forward so apparently it
was January 4th 2010 30 p.m. Lake Forest
Illinois which is a suburb of Chicago
now this witness who is not named in in
the source we're using here but he
claimed that he was standing outside and
he saw a triangular-shaped UFO much
bigger than a jet airplane than a 7.7
then a 747 and he said it was heading
over his house coming from the Northeast
he said it moved very slowly save his
stunned by its size and it made no salad
and it had a light display on the
underside
said it looked like about 500 individual
lights based evenly across the bottom of
it hmm he said it was a very surreal
experience
whoa and he said it went right over his
house headed Southwest now that was at
10:30 p.m.
okay the next reported sighting of this
apparently same thing was not until
several hours later that was a Melbourne
oh right now there null was the next one
to report it this was at 4:00 a.m. yeah
Melbourne Knoll owned a mini golf course
yeah and you can see him on the programs
he's quite a character he's an older guy
yeah you can can't tell he's kind of a
podunk but he seems cool he's cool he's
honest he passed his polygraph and he
Key's when it kicked it all off because
he told the cops about it yeah pretty
much I mean he so he went to his mini
golf course at four am because it was
freezing cold that night and he thought
the pipes were gonna freeze so he went
out there and he happened to look up
into the sky and he saw what he thought
was a really unusually bright star right
that's what he thought it was at first
and he didn't really think that much of
it he just looked up and said oh that's
a bright star that's odd turned his back
on it went back into the office came out
of the office and saw a flying house
yeah that's what he said that's how this
guy described it he said that it looked
like a flying 2-story house yeah he said
it was square right yeah there's a
square with a circular circular
arrangement of red lights on the bottom
of it windows on the side it had like a
another little second or third storey
like a little room on the top of it and
as it was going as it passed him and
went away he could see like a long light
going across the back of it with bars
and when you see the actual renditions
of it in some of the reconstruction so
you can see what he's talking about
where it looks like a house yeah because
he said it looked like it kind of had
windows like they lit up and then yeah
and you can kind understand maybe from
his angle
would have looked square yeah cuz he
said when he drew it it looked to
rectangular just look like a flying
house with a little story on topic and
now he said it was pretty low too right
was Louis slow and quiet and I was a new
Canon or he's one of the tops of trees
and it was the trees didn't move he said
it was eerie yeah he said nobody's gonna
believe me yes so he ran to the cop to
the police station up the street yeah he
yeah he basically went to Highland was I
think the closest police station so he
actually went there in person because he
thought no one would believe him and
said hey I saw this thing that looked
like a two or three storey house yeah
you know and so what happened then you
know what you know you know why he
thought it look like a house I can take
you back to the army that time I was
stationed in the Sinai Peninsula in
Egypt one time and we were there for six
months and part of my job was to watch
an airfield and we were on the lookout
for military aircraft landed at that
airfield because they weren't supposed
to be there under treaty we were there
to enforce a peace treaty I was writing
a letter at the time and planes had
never really used that airfield and out
of the blue an aircraft comes in for
landing and I just see this monster
military jet look like an attack jet
land so I hit the air come hey this is
jet it just landed you know so they said
come on up to the office fill out a
report so I go there and they ask me the
specifics of this aircraft what kind of
aircraft was it and I was like well what
did it look like was it a janitor
propeller plane oh well what color was
it it was military but what color was it
was it was camouflaged of some sort was
a jet I think some kind of a tag jet
looked like it said okay we'll go pile
into the truck we'll go drive down there
and see what airplane it was you get
down there and when we [ __ ] when I
finally found the aircraft it was a
c-130 cargo plane and it was orange and
what the reason why I tell that story is
that if you're not psychologically
prepared to see something and it
surprises you got to know
a lot of times if you don't have if you
only have a few seconds to observe it
you're out your your view of it is gonna
be really distorted you won't you won't
see it clearly yeah and I think that's
what happened to him he came out and it
surprised him and the only thing he
could really equate it to was a square
house with a bunch of windows in it yeah
and he had a little bit more time or had
he been prepared to see it he would have
seen it more clearly and I think it's
why the cops saw it more clearly because
they knew they were out there looking
for something and yeah I mean the first
guy was just he just happened to be out
there and so I really can't blame the
old guy for describing it as a house I
just described an orange an orange
propeller-driven cargo plane as an
attack jet yeah yeah well close yeah and
that's soft for me about three seconds
it was on the ground coming in for a
landing
yeah but that's there's nothing to kind
of people keep in mind when you see
something you don't expect it yeah and
then your memory memory will add things
like details on later to okay the next
topic seat was wet now the next cop to
see it basically so so Melbourne goes to
the cops and tells the dispatcher what
he saw and he tells it what direction
that's moving in so the dispatcher calls
officer at Barney who is with the
Lebanon Illinois Police Department and
she and at first he thinks it's a joke
because she said hey this guy just came
in and said there's a [ __ ] house yeah
and you might want to go and look out
for that
so at Barton he gets in his car and he
goes so he goes and and I think there's
like recordings of the call of him
saying was this a DUI yeah I mean once I
find it what do you want me to do with
it yeah he's and stuff like that what do
I do if I see it yeah
so he went out looking now he's and he
saw it yeah um it was going in the
direction of Summerfield Illinois you
know he turned on his overhead lights
and went south on Route four and then
east toward Summerfield
and apparently now I guess like I said
there was a documentary made about this
and it was kind of like a big deal of
all the cops saying it and stuff like
that but some other people came forward
later and said they had seen it too
there was apparently another witness in
Summerfield Illinois and they said that
they saw this craft for about two
minutes and they said it was only at
nine hundred feet altitude hello yeah
they said they saw it from about eight
hundred feet away they said it was about
twice the size of a c5 cargo plane okay
um and he said there were bright lights
around the perimeter and it was a
triangular shape like a boomerang
he said Ron this witness did not see
lights at the rear right some of the
other witnesses did but they said they
didn't they said it was moving slowly
also they said it was they said it was
about as slow as a plane coming in for a
landing
and he said he could he could hear a
slight sound not loud but he said it
kind of sounded like a car engine but
from Bury but from far away yeah I think
I remember he said it sounded like a
welded v8 engine yeah from about a
distance of about 40 feet yeah so not
silent but not really loud and he said
it was moving very slowly toward he said
it was moving in a West so the cop from
Lebanon officer Barton he drove toward
where where the thing had been spotted
or where it was going he pulled off the
road shut off his engine shut off his
emergency lights and he wanted to see if
he could see it or hear anything now he
filed a report when he got back that
said he saw a very large triangular
craft yeah they say triangular a narrow
head shaped yeah that was pretty like
there lengthened triangles yeah usually
agree oh yeah most of them said
Arrowhead or a boomerang or something
like that well sometimes they say
meringue with an arrow and Eric we're
triangular like an elongated triangle
yeah so officer Barton said that the
lights were blinding on it much brighter
than an airplanes lights said I had a
white light at each corner and a red
blinking light in the on the bottom he
said that the one the white light in the
front was shooting a shaft of light
toward the ground without actually
lighting the ground up so not like a
spotlight he said that the craft was
hovering at about a thousand feet so
similar to what the other witness had
said they said nine hundred feet and he
said he couldn't hear anything now he
turned his car engine off so he could
listen to it but he said he didn't hear
it making any noise he said the back of
it was a single white bar right with
kind of like a multicolored rainbow
strip through the middle right yeah yeah
right um now he said that the the craft
hovered a bit and then started going
away he said that before it left it made
a pivoting turn a flat spin yeah that's
how it turned it just spun on its axis
and then begin to move away but slowly
not not quick okay now he said yeah he
said the back of it had a like white
lights all along the back and then there
was a thin strip of multicolored lights
like rainbow down the middle of it yeah
so that's what he described saying and
he drew little sketches of it or
whatever and I think the sketches I'll
put them in the YouTube video but the
little sketches he made there's some
good animations of it too yeah but um so
officer Barton radios and he says you
know tells him what he saw and he tells
in which direction that's going in he
said now if he the the officer from
Shiloh which was about six miles away
he said now if the officer from Shiloh
looks up in the sky soon he should be
able to see it because that's the way
it's going yes apparently was really big
yeah and all the cops are listening to
each other on the radio yeah they're all
they're all using teamwork to try to get
a look at this thing yeah so basically
it was less than a minute after Barton
um you know went on the radio and said
where it was going and there was a
police officer in shiloh the next town
down the road named David Martin and he
said on the radio that he saw something
but didn't know what it was he was going
eastbound in Shiloh and then he spotted
it and it looked like I'm sorry I've
called what looked like a triangular
shaped object with three down reporting
lights which is also what the person's
like shining down like spotlights but
they weren't reaching the ground which
is kind of funny looking at and they
drop their drone it do you think they
drone it they've drawn it in a way to
where it looks very unnatural
very odd yeah but I would imagine that
be eerie to see that yeah now okay so
David Martin said he said that the
lights were toward the rear right hurry
of them yeah he said all three of them
everybody else said it was at the corner
said they were at the corners yeah it's
almost like the lights move yeah and the
first thing they said it was first
witness that it was a pattern of lights
evenly spaced throughout the whole
bottom of it like five hundred over
remember yeah that's right it's almost
kind of like there's an LED display
underneath the bottom of the other thing
yeah it's weird because it seemed like
people were seeing roughly the same
thing but the pattern of lights they saw
was different that may have some does
the angle the angle of approach that
angle you're look at you're seeing it
from and also like I said when you're
startled by something sometimes your
memory of it isn't clear right exactly
now David Martin this is the cop from
Shiloh he said that he saw a red and a
green blinking light which was in front
of the three white lights yeah so the
order was different yeah instead of in
the middle and he did the same thing he
pulled over the side of the road and
turned his car engine off to see if he
could hear it and he said he didn't
or anything he said that he thought he
couldn't determine exactly how wide it
was but he said it looked bigger than a
football field yeah um he said that he
could see that it was low enough that he
could see some detail on the bottom of
it and he said it looked like building
blocks or like plumbing yeah I've heard
it described another guy he said it
didn't look flat on the bottom I was
listening to some audio interviews from
these cops and two of them said
something that was very similar they
said that it looked like it was put
together in pieces like a little Lego
break Legos and that you could see
details and irregularities underneath
the bottom of it kind of like like he
said pipes and plumbing or something
reminiscent of a of a like a battleship
that's a word that he write yeah like
something oh yeah naval battle shape of
a naval battleship yeah so it wasn't
smooth now here's the weird thing one of
the cops also said that he saw at an
angle and underneath all that
irregularity was what what he thought
was an image of the stars above it being
projected below it in other words that
it may have had a slight camouflage
ability like cloaking like like a cloak
that it was trying to project the Stars
that were behind it down on the bottom
of it which really doesn't make sense to
me because you have these huge lights on
the damn thing and then you're gonna try
to project stars that you know - yeah
they think they're fool it didn't make
sense but maybe maybe that was just a
cops but interpretation of what he was
seeing yeah maybe it just had a thin or
like a maybe had like a coating of
Lights underneath it because remember
the first witness said he thought he saw
five hundred evenly spaced lights right
yeah so maybe that's what he was seeing
maybe the lights go you know where it
would sometimes be turned off sometimes
they'd be turned on maybe sometimes if
it get give like a big just kind of
glitter some of them would light up
maybe I thought he was seen I don't know
but you know that it's difficult to know
what they saw
they were under stress and I think they
were surprised yeah that's it
right so basically off officer Martin
this was the guy from Shiloh he was
gonna get out of his car and try to get
a better look at it
but then the ship he said it suddenly
shot away in the blink of an eye
yeah whereas before it had been everyone
else reported moving very very slowly
now he said it was like it was gone
yeah former correctly he estimated that
it then it moved six miles away to the
nearest town in this very very quickly I
think he said within about three seconds
so that would be almost three thousand
miles an hour right the g-forces on
acceleration and deceleration would rip
a normal aircraft apart it would kill
everybody in there yeah so you're not
talking about if that's an accurate
description of how it moved yeah you're
not talking about normal propulsion very
very strange yeah it is kind of weird so
then the next town on its little route
was Milstead Illinois and like we said
the cops have all been listening to the
radio so they all know like which is a
common thing is going because officer
Martin said hey it's moving west yeah so
the next guy officer craig stevens and
at 4:28 m this guy's actually the best
witnesses yeah for 28 M he spotted a
triangular craft and he said it was
moving very slowly past him he was
parked he was looking for it because he
heard about it on the radio so he was
looking in the sky for it and he saw it
and um the dispatcher he called the
dispatcher and said I see it I'm looking
at it right now and she asked if he was
kidding
they say it was huge and he said no it's
huge huge and he said he also said that
he saw a red blinking light on the
underside and he he kind of drew a
picture of it kind of looks like that
kind of looks like an arrowhead or like
a you know it's triangular but with dish
to the distant bodies yeah
that was the sketch he drew of it and he
also drew he said that the that the
light on the back was strobing yeah he
said a strolling kind of like you know
the the car kit from Nitro Nightrider
yeah it was going back and forth we just
went in one direction start bright in a
go dim and it was white it was it a
white strobe along the back of it with
three bright white lights inside of it
and black lines like bars going down it
they had some really good animations of
it in one of the the videos that I saw
maybe we put some of that in in the
video shows show people what it looked
like but it was quite hard really not
conventional it's not like something you
put on the back of a military craft yeah
and now actually um Craig Stevens he's
the one that um that said he saw the
star projection oh there was the bottom
yeah he's the one that said that and
he's also the one that said the bottom
of it looked blocky like in naval
battleship yeah and he's got pretty
close up yeah when it was close to him I
think it was a few thousand feet away
right yeah five hundred feet off the
ground right out an out over a field and
he could hear a buzzing like a low
buzzing tone he said it sounded kind of
like a transformer but the the pitch was
lower and you know one of the videos I
saw you know they gave an estimate kind
of a reproduction of what he said it
sounded like almost like a foghorn yeah
weird now Craig Stevens happen to have a
Polaroid camera in the trunk of his
police car yeah so thinking quickly he
went to the trunk he got the Polaroid
camera out and he took a picture of it
and they got a pit road now the picture
yeah is not super great no because one
it was cold out and the camera like the
picture didn't want to come out of the
camera because I guess the [ __ ] was
frozen in there but also when the
picture came out it was very very dark
and it's kind of far away as you can't
really tell what the picture just three
dots a light that are overexposed and
kind of stretched out over the camera a
little bit will picture that I know of a
real flying saucer or a UFO and it sucks
because the picture is so dark that you
can't really I mean you can't get any
sense of perspective you can't tell how
big it is you can't tell it far away it
is because the you know there's nothing
in there to compare it but it's proof
that there was an object there there was
something there yeah it sure does not
look like a plane no if it was a perfect
representation of what he was describing
I'd call [ __ ] on it well yeah
because you think that looks like
something that you just take it spur of
a moment it's almost 4:30 in the morning
yeah totally dark out yeah it's totally
dark so you can see the Polaroid it does
have a flash on it but if something's
far away far yeah the flash doesn't he
wouldn't come out yeah so all you can
kind of see is like three smudges of
light you can't tell how big it is there
anything like that but you know that's
that's [ __ ] and you know they've done
like enlargements and tried to do an
analysis of the picture it's three
bright lights and a couple of dim lights
yeah there's a little red one you can
see is is the red flasher yeah and you
can kind of see like when when the
picture is enhanced a little bit you can
almost kind of see a suggestion of like
some kind of thing that looks like the
back of a machine yeah sort of it looks
like little little lines or like little
I don't know it looks kind of like the
back of something yeah that's weird but
um
actually let's we're at 25 minutes so
let's take a break right now and then
we'll about this and then we'll go back
and talk about the rest of the timeline
and then we'll talk about what it could
have been there's some tactical theories
and stuff like that
so we will be back in just a few minutes
oh cast
dead sexy podcasts I'm your host Armand
Rose Amelia Fridays exclusively on
project entertainment network where I
interview authors publishers
Enders forests filmmakers narrators the
lady from Walmart whoever I feel like
talking to that's every Friday arm cast
right here on Project Entertainment
Network if you're into cosplay corset
Rhys steampunk gothic or rockabilly
clothing shoes and accessories then you
must visit subculture corsets and
clothing either online at
www.haddadtoyota.com and receive a 10%
discount on your entire order and if
you're a full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carries sizes 4 through 4x
and they have men's clothing as well
that's subculture corsets calm and use
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount go check out their website now
subculture corsets calm or when
traveling through Jacksonville Florida
stop in and check out their store at the
Avenues Mall
Podcast the brands [ __ ] and heavy metal
properties with a common connection
brought to you by house token jumped
look max max smoking old hades and ours
real mordecai featuring interviews and
more with the stars of medellin flora
the paranormal nonfiction tell whether
go to WWJD AFRICOM or search Amazon for
the Jenny Ashford author page
okay we're back and we're talking about
the Illinois UFO yeah the Sinclair
triangle st. Clair triangle that's
ethylene I've only heard it called UFO
was over Illinois or UFO that's weird
so before the break we were talking
about okay Craig Stevens and he took a
Polaroid of it
now the next officer in the UFOs line of
fire was in Du Bois Illinois which what
kind of city name is that and I don't
know I thought it was DUPLO like DUPLO
Blanco
no it's du Bois sounds like sounds like
a character in Star Wars yeah so the
next the next cop was Matt Janie of the
Depot Police Department and he had also
been hearing all the radio chatter about
the UFO and so he started looking for it
he was on Interstate 255 and he was
going northbound and he pulled over to
to look for it and then another officer
came by and they were kind of joking
about you know hey UFO out there isn't
that funny ha ha ha cos you know ok it
was over sin calm their central
communication for st. Clair County so
they were all hearing it in different
cities and they were kind of like you
know having a good giggle about it if
they hadn't seen it but then so then
Jane II saw it he drove through right a
little way and then he saw a really
brightly lit object to the east now
everybody else said that it was low like
between 500 and 1000 feet off the ground
officer Janie said that it was at a
plane altitude yeah like 20,000 20 30
thousand feet he said you know where a
plane would be so whether he was seeing
the same thing that everyone else was
saying or whether he just saw a plane he
tried to look at it through binoculars
and just saw white lights of some
colored lights yeah I think he was just
seeing an unrelated aircraft he might
have been because he was looking at it
through um through binoculars like you
said and he said that he thought the
lights
the crafts were brighter than aircraft
lights but that's that distance yeah how
can you tell yeah um you know he said
that the red light on the bottom he's
like it looked really big even though
the craft was far away so he didn't
think it was an airplane but like I said
because no I have no one
yeah and really if it had been so low
and then suddenly a couple miles later
he seasoned its way up where a
commercial aircraft would be well the
thing could move quickly that's sure
what I just tend to think that he was
looking at a regular airplane but you
know who knows
now they had another guy who was
listening to his police scanner a
civilian yeah listen to his police
scanner he ran out there and saw at what
seven o'clock or six o'clock in the
morning well the next guy actually the
next guy was um was gone was on his way
to work oh there's another guy yeah okay
and this was a couple hours later this
was 650 a.m. and this guy's Steven
Winnicott he was a teacher and he was on
his way to work and he was from
Centerville and he saw an object in the
sky that was stationary and he also said
it was very big it was triangular had
two very bright white lights with little
smaller lights around it hmm
he didn't stop the car but he reported
it to the newspaper so he basically I
think he's it sounded like he said it
was just like hanging there like it's
okay and that was I think that was
pretty much the last sighting of it that
day okay now what okay other than the
gut the Janie guide that I think
probably just saw Blaine right clearly
these people were kind of all seeing
something and it was a weird thing yeah
right
was it a UFO like well yeah it was a UFO
but was it an alien spacecraft is the
bigger
well I would just go buy this what the
cops saw yeah those three cop the first
three cops well actually you had the guy
who said he saw he the guy who thought
was a house yeah and then what are the
three cops after that yeah right and
then one of the fourth cop who might
have money to spend see they might have
just been a plane well you know that it
happened yeah because there's just too
much documentation too many unrelated
witnesses so they did see something they
passed the lie detector tests later on
ten years later it's just the
identification of the craft was it a
secret aircraft was it a alien
spacecraft or was it something else yeah
now there's a skeptical yeah this I mean
obviously because the craft was
triangular um some people said oh maybe
it was a stealth um which is triangular
but it doesn't have the same light
configuration here fixes yeah the flight
characteristics are not the same it
makes a lot of noise it doesn't fly as
low as these people report I see a b2
you know the seen an aircraft you know
you see a flying wing aircraft all right
yes you know you hear jet engines and
the speed at which it travels yeah now
slightly more believable is the fact
that it could have been now it should be
noted that there is an Air Force Base
right around that area yeah however
evidently it went right over that Air
Force Base yeah and it did go right over
the Air Force Base now that Air Force
Base Scott Air Force Base yeah that is a
mainly a medical Air Force Base is it
not yeah medical so it wouldn't be some
place where you'd really be testing
secret aircraft or anything like that
although now didn't they deny that any
that they had seen anything even though
it looked like it should have flown
right over it yeah they said they didn't
see anything and then when pressed they
said well there Tower wasn't up and
at that time there wasn't which is kind
of suspicious I think they did see it
that didn't want to make a comment I
think there I think they were in a jam I
don't think they know what it is either
yeah maybe not and you know they're not
they're not gonna admit to people that
yeah we saw an aircraft that we couldn't
control we didn't know what it was must
have been something extraterrestrial but
we don't know they're never gonna say it
like that
he's gonna say yeah we don't know you
wouldn't see any we didn't see it there
was nothing yeah it was flares but um so
but a little more a little harder to
explain away was um the the other
skeptical viewpoint that it might have
been a blimp because the American blimp
company is the largest operator of
blimps like advertising blimps in that
area and evidently I mean it being a
blimp could explain one why it was so
low - why it was flying so slowly three
the different light configurations
because blimps often have different
light configurations or LED screens for
different advertising purposes sounds
like and yeah and they're not very loud
I mean they have they have an engine but
they're not very loud and evidently the
route that this that this craft took
would have been the route that a blimp
would have taken if there was you know
say an event in Indianapolis or what
have you
like from Indianapolis to the
headquarters or whatever so some people
are saying that maybe it was a blimp the
thing is is that that whole theory rests
on the idea that four people can miss
identify a blimp and I just I just don't
I just don't see it yeah that does seem
like yeah I'm sorry close range
yeah and they said no it's triangular
and the squares the Lord said it was
square right and we see blimps all time
over
over Orlando they're not difficult to to
identify yeah I've never thought that
was a UFO ever no you look at you go
yeah laughs yeah it's a boy cigar shape
yeah so I don't know if I'm really no I
don't believe it I don't believe it was
a blender yeah like it seems
coincidental but oh yeah that's the
route but but you have to think to one
this was the middle of the night so why
would a blimp be farting around in the
middle of the night there's the other
idea that it could have been a stealth
is a plan or stealth blimp which is
deltoid blimp lighter than air saw the
body blimp that can defy radar but the
problem is is that there's a lot of
problems with that idea a stealth blimp
would never be flown low and slow near a
civilian area so that people could see
yeah letting the civilians see it is the
same as letting Russia and China see it
and the flight characteristics the rapid
acceleration that would tear a solid
body zeppelin up and kill the crew
unless it was maybe a drum but this is
year 2000 yeah i guess they had drone
technology but still the g-forces on a
solid body set up and it would tear it
apart what they were describing i saw
one thing the performance that they were
describing even if it was something that
was lighter than air like an arrow
lighter that lighter than air solid body
Zeppelin that type of acceleration would
would have to be some kind of an exotic
propulsion and all the exotic
propulsions that they know about today
are all theoretical and they all require
a bike about a gigawatt of electricity
and that's a that's what a what a
full-size nuclear power plant puts out
all right you know to run a C so now I
don't believe it was a secret craft it's
just I mean why would you have a stealth
Zeppelin and then put a bunch of lights
on it yeah that's that doesn't really
make any sense well we're making a
stealthy craft let's make it super
fabulous and
visible whatever this thing was it
wanted to be seen it knew it was being
seen yeah now I should I should say that
the FAA told the paper and that it was a
boy but you know they're gonna do what
they do right they set the records of
the blimp no not that I know of yeah not
that I think gets back to like Phoenix
lights well it was flares yeah and in
the Phoenix lights videos the video that
they commonly show that is flares yeah
but the army dropped those after the
site the mass sighting happened yeah
that's it to muddy the waters right
there's only one real video of the
Phoenix lights and it's a it's it's a
v-shaped formation of lights and it's a
real grainy low-quality video it's
hardly ever seen and would be just lost
on and be lost among the other YouTube
videos because it's so unimpressive yeah
I guess a lot of Amar though raagh UFO
videos yeah I think I mean so well one
person actually did videotape dudes the
so-called P Phoenix lights yeah he's one
of the supposed craft and it just looks
like a grainy video with five likes in a
v-formation
that's all you can see you know low res
video at night
so either aliens are coming here in
triangular-shaped crafts or the or some
government somewhere has a bunch of
sneaky triangular-shaped aircraft that
they're flying around
I don't know that acceleration that's a
lot if that's accurate which it could be
it's difficult to say this is why this
is one of the best UFO cases what was
that yeah cuz I mean obviously they all
saw something yeah and they can't all
have been so Dominique
to misidentify a plane or am I mean I
could see one guy doing that but and you
know the kind of the kind of espionage
something like a stealth blimp would do
it's not really needed anymore you have
satellites they're really good at that
kind of stuff yes I don't even think the
Russians
be interested in that yeah you don't
really need that anymore not in this day
and age now but um I don't know man what
well here's the thing it's let's say I'm
not saying it's aliens okay yeah it
could be aliens I don't know I'm sure
there's aliens out there someplace I
mean the galaxy is the universe is
enormous yeah whether they would come
here or not whether they would be
interested enough to come here like what
are they doing are they just checking to
make sure we're not [ __ ] up the
planet or not I wouldn't think so maybe
it's just a drone if that was an
extraterrestrial craft
maybe it didn't even have passengers
maybe it was just a robotic drone and
maybe it was just doing what it was told
to do look at stuff or send photos back
I don't know hmm oh it's just a good
case to point out to the to the viewer
in to the fans that if you want to if
you want to you know look at it good you
have okay someone that I think is
credible that's this one yeah I think
it's one of the best ones I do like I
have to say that me and Tom talked about
this quite a bit and I do like your kind
of I don't know I don't know if I'd call
it a theory your hypothesis let's say
about if aliens are visiting like you
don't think that they're really that
interested in humans or even like you
know they don't want anything from us or
anything like that he's like they're
almost like Park Rangers like we're just
we're just kind of at the periphery of
their of their domain let's say yeah and
they're just like kind of messing around
like just checking well maybe it could
be a situation where we think this is
our planet but maybe it's their planet
we might be within their star system and
they've claimed this territory yeah and
then even see us as a threat we're just
a wild life on the planet yeah kind like
you go out to your backyard and there's
ants and bugs out there yeah you don't
care about those ants and bugs that's
your backyard
yeah you ask those ants those ants are
going to tell you that that's their home
yeah probably situation like that comes
down just looks at the plants and looks
at the wildlife we're a part of the wild
life and then splits making sure
everything's all right that you know
maybe
are not coming here you know making sure
that they're not coming here and
violating their territory you know could
be something that dumb I like to think
they're not interested I like to think
that it's just alien children not a
boring failed trip that would be
millions of years have had ahead of us
they'd be a superior species we would
just be bugs to them that's what yeah
that's what I'm think it's like why
would they care and why would they need
anything from us no I don't think they
need that's why I can't buy any of these
like alien attack movies or anything
like that because it's like if they were
advanced enough to get here why the [ __ ]
would they need at that they could go
anywhere they have access to everywhere
yeah they have access and there's like
the [ __ ] is the same all over the
universe they would be a superior
species they'd be godlike compared to us
yeah so why would they bother their
technology would be like magic from our
point of view right so I don't think
they would bother they wouldn't bother
coming by here unless they were just
curious or unless it was some alien
scientist doing a study or something
they probably would not see us as
intelligent no and they would probably
not see our technology well I don't see
most humans probably not see our
technology as technology either no hey
abroad that you kind of like what when
you go up to a paper wasp nest you're
gonna call that nest technology to us
yeah I mean you know the aliens were
still like hitting each other with rocks
and [ __ ] like that yeah I think you see
us like bees probably which you know
fair enough how much time is that so you
know if you aliens are out there and we
still well we're at 43 minutes let me
take a call let's take a call no one can
call us this isn't life no more use
where they can find this video where
they can find the videos of this case
though because this is actually a good
UFO case well yeah if you were gone if
you look on YouTube there's a couple of
there's a couple of documentaries about
it probably the most the best-known one
was the Discovery Channel did one and
it's just called UFOs over Illinois yeah
so uh you know you can just search
YouTube for that and you can find and
that has I think that has pretty much
all the police radio dispatch calls
interviews with the witnesses because I
think a couple of the witnesses are dead
now yeah the main witness is the main
cop guy I saw it for the longest he died
of cancer yeah not long after yeah he
was pretty young I don't even think he
made it to 40 poor guy
[ __ ] yeah yeah I didn't realize I
thought he looked pretty young in that
documentary and that wasn't that time
his 30s it was just in 2000 that wasn't
right just 16 years ago yes not an old
case yeah but um okay so have you said
all you wanted to say about this
particular case yeah it's unknown yeah I
don't it just doesn't really it doesn't
really strike me as a as a military
aircraft or civilian aircraft yeah and
the guys passed the polygraph test and
they believed it was extraterrestrial
yeah so Who am I to question them there
were the ones who saw it maybe if I saw
it if it was that damn impressive I go
yeah that's aliens you see one one of
these yeah I want to see one he wants to
see one but I don't think you know man
it's hard to commit to that one was that
an alien spacecraft could've been that's
all I can say but like I said I always
wonder like whenever whenever I think
yeah that was probably an alias but I'm
like why though why would they come here
why why would they come here and why
would they like fly down the road gonna
a dude
well maybe is just a drone yeah maybe
maybe just a drone you know it's doing a
routine check
maybe there's some aliens in it maybe
that air that that spacecraft that
you're looking at that you're seeing
maybe and that is the alien maybe it's a
living machine maybe they downloaded
their soul into this thing you know like
an artificial body yeah and it's maybe
it's a mortal and it can do that will
vast distances and it's that's warp
drive and all that that's pretty sweet
yeah I know it's you know one day you'll
see a UFO I know you really want to the
closest thing I've ever seen I was right
I used to work at night you know
and I was driving I was driving to work
and it was really dark out and I looked
up in the sky and I saw a huge fireball
yeah I like this story now I here's the
thing I did not immediately think it was
a UFO I immediately thought that's a
meteor and we're [ __ ] right because it
was big it was coming right at you in it
I mean well the first thing I thought
was a plane had exploded okay
that's the first thing I thought and
then I thought because this is hilarious
I saw it two days after I finished
reading the book by Phil Plait the
astronomer and it's called death from
the skies
and it's just like tells you all the
[ __ ] from space that could kill you yeah
and I had just read that like a couple
days before and then I'm driving down
the street and I see this huge [ __ ]
fireball in this guy how big was it if
you had it in your hand was it like this
and held it out would it be like the
size of a penny or if I held my head it
was actually more like the size of a
ping-pong ball okay really it was big
and just an explosion in this guy yeah
and did you see it move it looked like
it was moving yeah huh and like I said
first thing I thought [ __ ] a plane
exploded or the Space Shuttle exploded
or something like that because I mean
you know I saw you can tell how far away
it was no not really and then I thought
[ __ ] it's a meteor that's a dinosaur
killer right there well you know I was
freaking out and then like I got to work
and I had a ball that's almost the size
of the Sun yeah no it was big I'm that's
what I'm telling you it was big Wow and
so I got to work and I was like you guys
we're gonna get hit by a meteor so nice
knowing you yeah yeah whatever hit
already man yeah but it didn't light up
the nighttime sky not really no so it
must have actually still been way high
up in the atmosphere it must have been I
don't know because the weird thing was
then like you know obviously we didn't
get hit by a meteor because we're still
here but like then I kept watching the
news and like stuff like that and nobody
else had seen it huh nobody else saw it
so I don't know if it was just how long
was it up there for it was just a couple
it was just a few seconds and look like
it was falling going one side we had
going in a certain direction and burn up
it my don't
I mean you don't know well cuz I was
driving okay and then like you know I
was driving I didn't stop I had to look
look back to in the room yeah so I don't
know so you know that was a UFO in the
sense that it was unidentified but I
just thought I don't know I didn't think
crap but yeah it was a big ask me to
hear though that's what scared the crap
out of me but nobody saw it but Mesa I
guess ambitious and now I had not been
drinking
okay alright so anyway uh hope you
enjoyed the UFO show yeah yeah cuz I'm
you know I'm cold and I just you know
this was kind of short it's not that
short so anyway yeah you guys should
check check this case out this is yeah
yeah this is a good case lots of good
witnesses and whatnot and the animations
behind them are really kind yeah yeah
I'm the discovery show they did like
little computer animations of what the
people saw yeah so you know you can
check that out too yeah if you like our
show of course you should subscribe to
our youtube youtube channel or listen to
us on project entertainment network or
like our facebook page and our Twitter
page at 13 o'clock podcast and don't
forget we also have t-shirts at
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock five
different ones at the moment and I'll
eventually put up some other ones and I
think I said this last week but if you
have any ideas of designs you want to do
that you would like to see on a t-shirt
based off I'm sure you know based off of
any of our topics or any kind of weird
topic then let me know and I will try to
accommodate you eventually and I guess
that'll do it for this week's show
yep see ya see
you